es weht ein eisiger wind um die ecken
der wiener staatsoper an diesem
montagnachmittag im november
das macht ihnen nichts aus eine
verschworene gemeinschaft trifft sich
jeweils stunden vor der vorstellung beim
seiteneingang
es sind die sogenannten stehplatz lob an
liebhaber die sich anstellen um für
wenig geld einen startplatz zu ergattern
möglichkeiten jahres 56 begonnen habe
ich mit zwölf jahren 75 jahre für einen
stehplatz zahlt man gerade mal drei bis
vier euro
aber wenn zeit geld ist dann kostet er
ein vermögen
heute wird es keinen warte rekord geben
den stars treten keine auf dafür talente
die bei den stehplatz hlern auf
interesse stoßen
einlass drei stunden vor der aufführung
die kasse ist noch geschlossen
karten lassen sich nicht reservieren so
gedulden sich alle vorerst sitzend es
bleibt zeit fachwissen auszutauschen
etwa beim ring der nibelungen denen
dieser stammgast schon 40 mal gesehen
hat die enthusiasten kennen alle stimmen
besetzungen und inszenierungen
dieses fachwissen erlaubt ihnen auch mal
mutig buch zu rufen sollte bei der
premiere sein neuester regisseur oder
der bühnenbilder anwesend dann versuchte
sich und die leute müssen sich dann 10
über 15 jahre diese inszenierung
anschauen dann ist es so viel gekostet
hat der stehplatz ist eine klassenlose
gesellschaft jeder kann sich eine karte
leisten
doch mit sporadischen besuchern und
touristen haben diabetes nicht viel zu
tun
sie bleiben gerne unter sich ruth
strutzmann strikt gar für gleichgesinnte
ein kleid so manche berühmte musiker hat
sich seine ersten kenntnisse auf dem
stehplatz angeeignet auch dieser sänger
das ist auch das herz der oper das sind
nicht nur die einheimischen sondern auch
wirklich die internationalen opern
liebhaber die eben kurzfristig auf den
spielplatz gehen oder weil alles
ausverkauft es sich wie die stunde lang
hinstellen und das gibt uns sehen
eigentlich das beste feedback also ein
großer applaus vom stehplatz ist oft
mehr wert als vom kaluza 567 stehplätze
gibt es
es gibt nun die gute ausgangslage bis
zur nächsten station zu wahren
früher war oft gerade dann endlich ist
das ziel erreicht das starter jeder
markiert seinen platz mit einem
persönlichen gegenstand
wer diese markierungen nicht respektiert
muss die aufsichtsperson oder gar die
polizei fürchten derweil haben sich die
erfahrenen den begehrten platz im eck
ergattert der große vorteil ist dass es
hier vier euro kostet da unten kostet 50
mal so viel
und vermutlich wäre ich besser sehen als
die herrschaften vor mir ich sehe auf
jeden fall über alle drüber dann lauscht
der stehplatz wohlwollend dem stück
am schluss gibt es verhaltene zustimmung
mehr applaus allerdings verdient in den
augen der stammgäste die institution
stehplatz selber so werden sie schon
bald zurückkehren und sich manor
nochmals ansehen allerdings nur die
dritte vorstellung dieser jeweils die
beste